this was chad's president idris debbie
campaigning last week
early election results indicated he'd
won a sixth term in office
but debbie had reportedly joined his son
and other soldiers on saturday
to repel an attack by a rebel group in
the northern province of khanim
near the border with libya according to
the military he was severely injured
and on monday it announced his passing
it says it's created a transitional
military council led by debbie's son
and has suspended the constitution
a transitional government will be put in
place new republican institutions will
be put in place to facilitate the
transition by the organization of free
democratic and transparent elections
following the spirit of sacrifice
that the marshal of chatter fought for
all his life right up until his last
suffering
in the capital where people celebrated
debbie's election victory the night
before the announcement
there were mixed reactions
it's sad news the presidential elections
went off peacefully through to the
declaration of results by the election
commission
and then the next day we learned the sad
news of the death of the president
debbie
after being injured badly at the front
lines it's sad
news for the entire country
the news is surprising i'm moved by it
the rumors that are going around
about the transitional council give me
the impression that some information is
false
are already talking about dissolving
parliament that is delicate
we have a constitution so for me i'd say
it was a coup
and he was killed idris debbie was a
former military officer who came to
power in 1990
he faced numerous coup attempts and his
opposition accused him of ruthlessness
the rebel front for change and concord
group wanted to remove debbie as
president
it attacked a government position at the
border on election day on april 11th
chad's closest ally france provided its
military with logistical support and
intelligence
it seems like the the removal of debbie
has not changed the military situation
and as long as the military remains
largely loyal to his son which seems
likely to be the case given that he used
to be the commander
of the presidential guard and the chatty
army's best units
um he's a four-star general he's only 37
years old
um if he can keep that loyalty then
there's no way the rebellion can
can take advantage of that any more than
they could have under his father
more than 300 rebel fighters have
reportedly been killed in the fighting
during the past few days
that president debbie has now also died
in the fighting has shocked a nation
and made the security situation in the
wider sahel region
even more fragile heber morgan al
jazeera jamaina